zach thank you for joining us i love
your choice of shirt
but you were the first player voted out
of survivor 42 how are you feeling right
now i'm feeling great honestly i really
felt like you know this happened a while
ago
i've gotten to process it got to like
work through all the emotions and it's
just fun that i finally got to see the
experience play out now be past it
amazing and you got to make some history
you got to use your shot in the dark on
the first episode and from where i'm
sitting it looks like you made the
correct decision and using your shot in
the dark because it was a unanimous vote
so what tipped you off to use the shot
in the dark
um
i mean honestly what tipped me off to
use the shot in the dark was uh swathi
who was like the you know the sweetest
person ever and i really like i i bonded
so much with her out there and when she
can't even look me in the eyes
like going into tribal you get a good
sense like all right well if swathi's
not with me right now
then uh i don't have a good shot with
the other people either and were you
surprised that it was a unanimous vote
did you think that maybe someone would
be throwing a vote in another direction
no i mean part of the my reasoning for
using the shot of the dark was that i
knew it would either be unanimous me or
union unanimous tory i mean
going into tribal council like in those
final few hours those were really the
only names that were being brought up
so i kind of knew that like
uh either way
my vote wasn't going to make an impact
there so i might as well just
um
use it
increase my odds and then even if it
didn't work it's not like i would be
losing the game because i used my shot
in the dark
i mean i think you had a good read on
the situation i think that you made the
right choice in using it i don't know
i'm maybe i'm being biased but i think
unfortunately it just wasn't the right
scroll this time
so when we go back to the scramble
before tribal council do you feel like
you were slighted or wronged by drea
after tori threw you under the bus
i felt like i was slighted or wronged by
drea
yeah yeah so or
i know that when there was speculation
about tori um looking for the idol and
then it kind of came out that you won
you were one of the people speculating
do you feel like you were thrown under
the bus at all then
i don't think that drea threw me under
the bus necessarily because i don't
think that uh
i don't think i was ever truly working
with draya that much so it's kind of
like i don't blame her for targeting me
when like i wasn't i was you know
targeting her at the same time i feel
like if anyone tori was the one that
more so kind of
not necessarily threw me under the bus
because she didn't say my name but she
definitely was um where i was kind of
going back from the challenge being like
okay how were me and tori and like
swathi gonna figure this out
tori was very much like how am i gonna
survive right now and so that's probably
where i felt slated
right right well another relationship
that we saw on the episode was the
skinny boys alliance i thought it seemed
so fun it seemed like there was so much
potential there this alliance with you
and romeo was that partnership something
that you were actually hoping would make
would make you go far in the game or was
that something that was just kind of a
game talk early on
i mean there was i mean there was a no
potential for that ever existing not
because of anything we were doing but
because i mean look as someone who came
from the lulu tribe
if you look at the three men that were
on lulu and you compare that to the
three men who were on uh ika two blue
tribes
it was telling very different stories
so for a challenge that was so or for a
tribe that was so severely undermanned
um it was going to be really difficult
for both me and romeo to stick it out
because you know when we lose so
horribly in that first immunity
challenge you're kind of looking at like
okay
um how are we even going to survive as a
tribe and challenges and so me and romy
were always going to be two that were
like heavily looked at in terms of
private weakness and unfortunately romeo
just had the better connections than me
right
right
well that's interesting because i think
that a lot of people don't see that
there's a lot of complex tribe dynamics
that go into the game it's not just do
you use this advantage or do you vote
for this person and i want to ask when
drea came back from the summit as
viewers we didn't see what her
explanation was for what happened that
day and at least on the episode we
didn't see that she was targeted so what
really happened there and
why didn't she have a target on her
so drea definitely did have a target on
her um
she was one of the most talked about
people for the first few days actually
we climbed up the mountain and then we
climbed back down
and that nothing happened up there and i
was like okay well that's like you know
that seems like a waste of 15 minutes of
screen time honestly if that's true
um so i definitely
um was suspicious of her tori was
targeting draya because trey had thrown
her name out there i was closer with
tori i was happy to vote drayau
roxtroy also had some personality
conflicts with andreas it really seemed
like there were the numbers to getcha
out there and then the real stopping
point unfortunately was romeo because we
didn't realize at the time that um
romeo was so close with tori or not with
tory with drea and thanks to that it
would have been really difficult to uh
to sway gotcha
so do you have any regrets about your
gameplay is there anything that you
would change if you got to do it again
um i mean one of my biggest regrets
honestly is not watching sequester
season three because then i would have
gotten to see tori
and just really throw her under the bus
for that um so that's a big thing i
think that i would have talked a lot
more with drea i think that because her
name was out there so much i kind of
thought i didn't want to align myself
with a sinking ship but i don't think i
realized how much power she really had
out there specifically with romeo and
roxroy who i didn't even realize they
were working together because they
butted heads so often
um
so i think i would have like i aligned
with swathi and with um tori very
closely but they didn't really have any
power in the game unfortunately i mean
it was really drea and romeo were the
two that really had control of the tribe
in that moment and while i had a good
relationship with romeo um i just wasn't
close enough with drea unfortunately
well i saw on twitter you have this
survivor wall with photos of all of your
all-time favorite moments from all 41
seasons of survivor so if you could
choose one picture or one moment to
commemorate your survivor 42 experience
what would it be one picture one moment
from the uh the episode
from the episode or even your entire
experience
um
i think that there's
let's see
i think that if i could choose
one moment to represent the because it's
not just about me it's about the
survivor 42 experience i think it would
just be mary again hysterically stopping
i feel like that's going to be an
amazing gift for years to come oh yeah
all right so now you're going to be able
to watch the rest of the season
who are you rooting for to win survivor
42 um who am i rooting for to win
survivor 42
i mean i'm rooting for a lot of people i
think that from my tribe uh i'm
definitely rooting for swathi i
definitely think that she's an awesome
person and i uh i really i really can't
wait to see you see everything um
and then
what else am i rooting for rooting for
omer
i really liked domer out there i really
liked his uh all of his bird clothing
that we would always see him in
he was an easy person for me to uh to
instantly just uh want to see do well
and then i think the last one i'd say is
daniel because i really feel like
daniel went into the game basically had
worst case scenario happen of instantly
dislocating his shoulder and i thought
it was so cool how how well he took it
in stride and um you know how just
how much he he didn't let it let him
become a weakness in his tribe so i'm
really rooting for those three
yeah i hope that we can see daniel
bounce back from his stephanie lagrassa
moment
well zach
thank you so much for chatting today in
your short time on the show you made us
laugh
and we wish you all of the best
oh thank you so much
you